- Hey, new kid, your fancy clothes may play well in a big city like Carolina,
but here in New England, we dress like s--t.
- Ignore him.
- Dude.
- Pretends.
- He has.
- A long-distance friend.
- Tom is real. He lives in Tampa!
- Shine through the shade, baby. I just dance.
- [Boston sports radio:] If Cam dances, he should be covered in chowdah
and thrown in the harbor.
- Man, what?
- Haven’t you listened to the radio?
New England has banned dancing!
- So The Patriot Way is when we play a game but hate playing it?
- Well, Gronk was allowed to be fun because he was whiiiiiii—y we were winning.
- Man, other transfer students don’t have to deal with this!
- Awwwwwwww...
- Stay away from my team, Foles.
- All right, I'll be here when you need me!
- YOU’LL NEVER BE MY REAL DAD.
- BUT I’LL BE BEST MOTHERFLUFFIN STEPDAD YOU EVER HAD.
- I know what we need:
a black-and-white training Instagram.
- ♪♪♪ Now we Pats fans finally see ♪♪♪
♪♪♪ Brady was a system QB ♪♪♪
♪♪♪ New Patriots way ♪♪♪
♪♪♪ or the highway! ♪♪♪
- [Boston sports radio:] This is good. This gives Stidham more time to develop.
- Ok and one more thing, I'm sick of these New York comedy writers
and their internet cartoons that make fun of my people.
Why would I subscribe to this garbage
when I got Boston sports radio playing 24/7 and the Kelly's Roast Beef on Route 1.
And another thing, when it gets cold in Foxboro,
the PSI of a football goes down. Talk to a professor at MIT.